bien sûr vous avz rendez-vous à 19h45
avec le débat je sais que vous
l'attendez tous les jours le débat du
jour vous allez voir il sera là bien
entendu et 20h45 ne manquez pas ces
nouvelles infos sur Xavier du pont de
ligonis il serait vivant vous allez voir
histoire de fou qu'on va nous raconter
dans un instant vous avez vu cette info
un SDF condamné à de la prison ferme
pour avoir volé des vêtements pour
passer l'hiver au chaud comprenez-vous
cette décision il a été condamné à 8
mois de prison ferme par le Tribunal de
Narbon pour avoir volé des vêtements
chauds regardez
ça il y a quelques jours une vague de
froid déferlé sur la France une vague de
froid ça bat effectivement sur notre
pays tandis qu'on dénombre dans
l'Hexagone 330000 s domicile fixe un
sans abri de 27 ans frigorifié a décidé
le 14 janvier dernier de s'introduire
dans une maison pour y dérober des
vêtements chauds comme des chaussures
une doudoune une casquette et un
portefeuille mais malgré les
explications de son avocate il a vu la
porte ouverte il a saisi sa chance de se
vêtir ce n'est pas une effraction c'est
de la survie l'homme a été condamné à 8
mois de prison ferme alors
comprenez-vous cette
décision comme on dit euh il va y avoir
de deux écoles ici où il y en a qui vont
dire la loi et la loi normalement donc
Gill Verdes devrait mettre oui parce que
la loi et la loi pour lui ou bien qui
vont dire forcément l'esprit loi c'est
ce que je pense il y a l'esprit de la
loi et c'est ce que je dis à chaque fois
et je le pense ici aussi pour cette
c'est ça tient aussi bien pour ce cas-là
que pour d'autres cas qu'on a évoqué ici
il y a l'esprit de la loi mais
normalement ch berdez devrait mettre oui
pu il est toujours dans la loi mais là
apparemment il va être dans l'esprit de
la loi puisque c'est pas ça concerne pas
ses amis de la ça concerne pas amis il
est dans l'esprit de la lo quand il est
pas est dans l'esprit de la loi quand il
concerne il est dans la
loage non je ne pense
pas il est un petit peu tt pour s'en
prendre à lui c'est mon ami il m'a
manqué ce weekend c'est le seul qui m'a
manqué je suis touché en plus non non il
y a pas de vanne Derrien mais c'est
adorable ah non en plus j'étais beaucoup
avec Fatou donc j'étais obligé de faire
le taf non j'étais avec elle non mais
oui voulez dire quoi bah moi il y a y a
même dans le titre il y a quelque chose
qui me choque en premier déjà c'est
quelqu'un qui a volé et qui a pris de la
prison ferme ouais euh on met plus de
prison ferme pour rien les gens volent
on les laisse faire on en parle encore
on en a parlé encore la semaine dernière
en plateau des gens qui voulaient dans
les magasins les commerçants sont
obligés d'afficher les gens parce que il
y a pas de condamnation il y a rien et
là pour une fois que c'est un sans abri
qui vole quelque chose pour se couvrir
lui on le condamne donc là il y a
quelque chose de pas logique pour moi
déà
de Dér je vrais rappeler un truc le gars
qui a essayé d'écorger
d'écorger comprème est on a bonnesoui
parce qu'il avait du il avait déjà volé
il avait été condamné à 6 mois avec
surcis donc c'est la loi alors
évidemment je suis une des RAR à mettre
oui c'est pas sympa quand on lit ce truc
on a éid v que ce monsieur est chaud
d'abord il y a beaucoup d'associations
il y a quand même beaucoup de choses des
gens qui passent des marudes qui
distribuent des choses donc évidemment
ça peut faire de la peine mais il est
quand même rentré chez dans un dans une
maison il a volé il y avait de l'argent
dans dans les poches il l'a pas rendu et
surtout malheureusement il était en surc
donc c'est la loi alors je peux paraître
s dire qu'il y a d'autres gens à
condamner aussi mais ça bien sûr mais
toujours évidemment si on compare mais
voilà j'explique quand même c'est
important quelque chose il se ser Dani
le surc qu'il a pris les 6 mois de
surcis qu'il avait auparavant et c'est
pour ça qu' qu' passe à de la prison
ferme c'était pour un vol à
l'étalageavais faim
voilà c'est l'oire d'un SDF qui veut
simplement survivre
je mais on s'en fout mais oui non mais
juste parce que on le sait ça les gars
on on met au même plan un gars qui vient
pour faire du mal va pratiquement
égorger un me qui c'est presque un
homicide volontaire et un gars qui va
voler deux fois et donc non mais donc ça
veut dire que le c'est ça avec surs ça
veut dire que tu voles une orange un
jour et tu voles une orange après 2 mois
après tu vas prendre tu vas prendre la
prison ferme tandis que tu vas essayer
d'égorger un mec tu es en surc pour
l'instant là le procureur a étéfin ça a
été particulièrement loin parce qu'ils
ont rajouté 300 € pour préjudice auprès
des victimes ce monsieur est un SDF
évidemment que les 300 € il les a pas
puisque de toute façon
dis au même plan c'est même pas au même
plan parce que au même plan ça voudrait
dire que les deux vont en prison l'autre
va pas en prison parce que lui
il il l'a pas tué c'est son premier fait
et donc lui il va vraiment en prison il
va en prison pourquoi pour les pour il y
a des cas concret hein pour les choses
qu'on a expliqué parce qu'il avait déjà
du surcil alors moi pourquoi j'ai mis
oui j'ai mis oui à presque à contrecœur
parce qu'il va prendre 8 mois 8 mois
c'est énorme préféré qu'il prenne même
un mois c'était déjà trop il va passer 8
mois en prison juste parce qu'il avait
froid mais en même temps il avait déjà
du surcil il a volé un portefeuille il a
volé plein d'autres choses si tu si tu
fais pas un exemple pour lui c'està dire
que tous les SDF qui sont deh allez tous
voler dans les magasins parce que vous
NZ pas prison au mois de mai dernier au
mois de mai dernier il y a une fillette
qui a été égorgé et et le le mec a a
pris du surcis est-ce que tu trouves ça
normal quand tu comp il y a une
hiérarchie qui est totalement anormale
dans les
condamation les violences conjugales les
violences conjugales elles sont moins
condamnées qu'un vol le mec rentr dans
la
maison faudrait que a en prison lui
aille aussi en prison tu veux pas
comparer l'autre fois on avait une invut
pas comparer ça sert à rien on compare
pas c'est
beaucoupopir il y a deux problèmes déjà
pourquoi il y a des personnes qui
dorment encore dans la rue par ces
périodes de grand froid dans le
programme du président de la
République y avait cet engagement et
l'autre problématique c'est qu'on a une
justice à de vitesses on a des gens
aujourd'hui qui vendent de la drog qui
agressent des dans la rue qui tu même
parfois et qui ne vont pas en prison là
c'est un pauvre monsieur la loi et la
loi certes mais la justice est là pour
rendre justice au nom du peuple c'est
pour ça qu'il y a des jurisprudences on
napplique pas tout le temps la loi telle
qu'elle est donc c'est
scandaleux l'ESIT
deve qu'on voit tous les soirs sur ce
plateau mais c'est que la justice a des
gros problèmes de curseur que nous on a
envie on a envie de fermeter avec des
avec des multiéciviste et c'est pas le
cas et on a envie de justement d'esprit
de loi de compréhension pour des cas ex
e ce pvre SDF et là vraiment je dis que
la justice question-ce que parce que es
SDF tu as le droit de tout
faire ça ve dire SDF tu peux rentrer
dans un magasin voler des blousons voler
une moto voler n'importe quoi mais parce
que tu as pas de maison tu pouras faire
tout
n'importei
plil PL comprzette décision non à 65%
oui Gilles je vrais voir Gill parce que
Gilles normalement toi pour toi et je te
le dis gentiment normal pouri la loi et
la loi pourquoi suis faible je suis
faible face à ce marginal j'ai lu toute
son histoire il m'a touché face à la LFI
tu es pas fait non mais là là
franchement l'humanité a triomphé par
rapport à la loi à la justice et ça m'a
touché il n'a pas commis des fractions
la porte était ouverte la dernière fois
c'est pour manger il n'a pas à manger il
a 27 ans c'est un marginal pour se
nourrir il va voir des associations
caritativ il a rien m touch
[Applaudissements]
V d'ord et ensite j'aité touché
par je j'accepte le fait d'être
illogique j'ai été extrêmement touché
par son histoire voil il y a d'utr sujet
on va parler de la LFI dans 2 secondes
donc on y va molo